[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute pizza nudeln
nudeln gibt gar nicht aber bei uns kommt
kein pizzateig zum einsatz sondern wir
werden ihn dem backofen backen und dann
ist es ein pizza nudelauflauf und dafür
zeige ich euch jetzt die zutaten und 12
gesagt ihr werdet sich die ich das
schmeckt nämlich richtig richtig lecker
hier stehen die zutaten wir benötigen
passierte tomaten etwas zucker olivenöl
knoblauch und salz und pfeffer natürlich
ihr könnt euch aussuchen welche toppings
quasi und ich hab ja wie champignons die
haben wir nicht mag aber heute war
egoistisch dann habe ich rote paprika
und oregano ganz ganz wichtiges gewürzt
zwiebeln ein ei und film fresh könnte
auch entspannt nehmen
hier habe ich nur dinge die sind schon
abgekocht und gouda käse natürlich
vorgekocht nicht abgekocht danke für den
hinweis haben sagen ob man habe ich die
ganz normal al dente gekocht nach
packungsanleitung das macht ihr dann
einfach vorher und jetzt gehen wir über
an den herd hier habe ich nämlich schon
meine fahne und da gebe ich jetzt das öl
erhitzen das einmal
und jetzt die fein gehackten zwiebeln
darin andünsten
denkt dran immer schön die mittlere
stufe bei olivenöl schon mal gar nicht
die höchste stufe nehmen das verbrennt
dann ganz schnell und die züge müssen
auch wirklich nur gedünstet werden so
eine gute minute und dann gebe ich mein
knoblauch dazu
selbst habe ich das gemüse teilweise
schon angebracht bei den paprikas ist
das so ich mag das nicht so fest in
meinem pizza nudeln
deswegen habe ich jetzt angebraten und
die schaffung sollte direkt auf jeden
fall am brachten aber nur eine minute
das reicht schon und den brand
champignons nie waschen und sagen wie
sich mit wasser voll immer nur putzen
und meist gebe ich gleich erst dazu das
muss nicht unbedingt angebraten werden
jetzt gebe ich das hier einmal in die
passierten tomaten und verrührt das
schon mal
und jetzt muss die soße gewürzt werden
so typisch wie eine pizza halt bei
tomatensoße kommt immer eine prise
zucker dazu das hebt den geschmack also
es wird jetzt nicht süß dadurch es ist
ja wirklich nur eine prise und natürlich
ganz wichtig salz und pfeffer und das
allerwichtigste wie ich finde ist
oregano ohne oregano und geht gar nicht
es erinnert einfach so an pfizer
deswegen gebe ich dass ich ordentlich
was dazu und denkt dran ich schreibe
euch immer hat die ganz genommen
mengenangaben also wirklich teelöffel
weise in die infobox
dass wir soweit erledigt jetzt kommen
unsere gekochten nudeln zum einsatz die
gebe ich jetzt einfach mit dazu
und jetzt könnt ihr mal abstimmen glaubt
ihr dass diese nudeln hier reinpassen
ohne das was überschwappt ihr könnt ihr
gerne mal die umfrage abstimmen bevor
ihr euch also nicht vorstellen sondern
hier oben einmal abstimmen glaubte ich
schaffe es oder es wird überschwappen
wie immer fahrrad mich doch nicht
na siehste alle die jetzt für
überschwappen abgestimmt haben was seid
ihr nur für menschen
warum glaubt den ich an mich es hat noch
gerade so hingehauen
jetzt habe ich die nudelwasser einmal in
eine auflaufform gegeben so ganz leicht
verteilung sagt gestrichen und jetzt
kommt so ein bisschen unser topping sag
ich mal nach oben drauf damit das ganze
so ein bisschen aufgepeppt wird aber
lasst euch sagen es schmeckt auch so gut
ihr könnt auch jetzt in gouda käse drauf
geben
ich mache das jetzt so dass ich hier
noch etwas creme fraiche da könnt ihr
jetzt auch gerne schmal oder saure sahne
nehmen und da gebe ich jetzt mai dazu
und wird das ganze noch mal mit salz
pfeffer und oregano
das habe ich jetzt noch mal schön
verteilt und als nächstes kommt der käse
oben drauf ist wird er schließlich
überbacken tut mir noch einen gefallen
ob jetzt leider nimmt oder emmentaler
betzigau da macht es so dass ihr euch
den selber reif dass er den käse nicht
fertig aus dieser verpackung wollt dass
sich diese trends stoffe trennmittel
drin und so weiter und hier habt ihr
wirklich nur käse
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt unser pizza auflauf in
den backofen
den habe ich hier schon vor gehalts auf
200 grad ober und unterhitze und dann
packte ihn einfach in der unteren
einschub leiste so lange bis der käse
schön goldbraun wird
[Musik]
und fertig sind die pizza nudeln ganze
35 minuten hat zum ofen gedauert
es könnte auch bis zu 40 minuten dauern
je nachdem wie heißer ofen wird und zu
den mengen das reicht für ich bin mal
seinen sechs hungrige personen also wir
essen dann auch mal zwei tage oder ein
hungriger haben dass sie so ein zuhause
gehabt ansonsten wenn ihr vielleicht zu
dritt oder zu viert und halbiert die
menge einfach man weiß ja nie weiß wie
viel ihr seid die vier personen seit er
im haushalt das ist doch mal eine gute
marktforschung schreibt mir das doch mal
rein dann weiß ich wie ich die zutaten
in zukunft so regeln soll
wie viele personen seit ihren haushalten
ja ich denke die meisten haben so vier
bis fünf menschen im haushalt schafft es
doch mal ein das wird mich jetzt das
interessiert mich jetzt richtig brennen
und ansonsten das video in licon fleißig
teilen wenn es euch gefallen hat erzählt
anfreunden davon und cousinen und tanten
und onkels und ja dann freue ich mich
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten mal wieder
dabei sein
ja und ob instagram und facebook freue
ich mich natürlich über eure fotos und
verwendet den hashtag ich s kitchen dann
sehe ich das auch fleißig okay bis dahin
tschüss
dort fressen
[Musik]